امريكي كان يوم من الايام مرشح للرئاسه
ونافس هلري كلينتون والترامب وكان كمان
سنتر اكثر من مره والان بيشغل منصب سنه
الولايه
صاحب شخصيه متفرده ودائما لاسلوب ومواقف
وتصريحات خلينا يعني نوصفها
بالمختلفه وهو نشط على المنصات وحساباته
شغاله على طول واليوم هو نجم تيك توك مو
بسبب حسابه اللي فاتحه على المنصه من
عشرين عشرين وعنده عليه مليون و400 الف
متابع وعشره ملايين لايك وانما اليوم منجم
على تيك توك بسبب فيديو طلع فيه بالغلط
خلينا نشوف المقطع
[موسيقى]
مثل
شخص دخل في الفيديو خربوه لكنه انتبهوا
وطلع فورا من كادر الكاميرا ولما ندقق طلع
الشخص
وانتشر الفيديو والكل سريع علق عليه ويضحك
حتى البنت نفسها على حسابها شغاله كلها
على نفس الفيديو اللي من خمسه ثواني حولها
لنجمه هي كمان
من ابرز التعليقات اللي انجهلت انه هذا
الفيديو بيعبر عن شخصيه بيرني تماما
والمقصود الشخصيه اللي موسى لعن اي شيء
وبتتصرف بتلقائيه وردات فعلها حقيقيه
والناس تذكرت واحده من ابرز هذه اللقطات
واللي تحولت الى ميم ونعمل من نادي
حفل تنصيب بايدن في 2021 جالس على واحده
من هذه الكراسي اللي بتنطوي ووقتها كان في
كورونا وتباعد وتعابير معبره جدا عن قد
ايش هو مستمتع باللحظه وغير لابس القفازات
الشهيره هذا غير صوره وهو بيصور الحفل من
تلفونه وصور القفازات وقديش كبيره عليه
عموما في الفيديو الجديد هذا على تيك توك
اتضح ان النجم مو بس برنيسان ففي نسخه
اطول من الفيديو طرح فيها انه زوجته كانت
طلعت قبله وخربت الفيديو اصلا واعتذرت
ووراها طلع اللي لحق نفسه وطلع من قدام
الكاميرا بس من بعد ما اعطانا نظره تحولت
اليمين هي كمان
[موسيقى]